hi everybody i'm here today again with
greg hurwitz an old friend of mine a
former student from harvard um
we've talked before and we've got some
exciting things to talk about today i'll
give you some background on greg first
greg is a new york times number one
internationally best-selling author of
20 thrillers including out of the dark
coming out in 2019 and two award-winning
thriller novels for teens
his novels have won numerous literary
awards grace top 10 lists and have been
published in 30 languages
he's written screenplays for or sold
spec scripts to many of the major
studios including the book of henry and
written developed and produced tv for
various networks
he's also a new york times best-selling
comic book writer having penned stories
from marvel wolverine and punisher and
dc batman and penguin he's published
numerous academic articles on
shakespeare taught fiction writing in
the usc english department and guest
lectured for ucla and for harvard in the
united states and internationally
in the course of researching his
thrillers he sneaked onto demolition
ranges with navy seals swum with sharks
in the galapagos and gone undercover
into mind control cults
herwitz grew up in the bay area while
completing a ba from harvard and a
masters from trinity college oxford in
shakespearean tragedy he wrote his first
novel he was the undergraduate scholar
athlete of the year at harvard for his
pole vaulting exploits and played
college soccer in england where he was a
knox fellow
so that's
greg everybody
it's quite an intro i think i'm just
gonna have you follow me around
everywhere and read that before i enter
a room
dislikes me yeah like yeah exactly
that's right that's the sort of intro
that makes everyone hopes you're a real
son of a after reading an intro
like that so they can they can morally
dislike you yes the best thing yeah
there's a lot to morally dislike jordan
as you know yeah yeah so we're not going
to talk too much today about
greg's previous exploits uh instead
we're going to talk about some of the
work he's been doing in the political
realm recently and the reasons for doing
that so greg i'm going to let you take
that away
well so
look i write thrillers and i have the
shorthand that i always give is that
about half of my friends are born again
christian navy seal snipers and half my
friends are gay aclu lawyers
and i tour equally in the red and blue
states my readership is very very
diverse and i think because of that i
have a real ear for
the the buzzwords and phrases and
ideological shorthand that really shut
people down
um that just make them stop listening um
my own politics i'd say i'm a bit more
of a classical liberal um
and one of the things that i talk a lot
about is there's certain phrases that
we've grown up with from both sides that
just make people completely stop and
it's not dissimilar to what we're trying
to do when we're writing right if you
write and use buzzwords and catch
phrases and cliches it's less
interesting if you already know what you
think before you start writing and
there's no room for discovery along the
way then you're not it's not real
writing it's propaganda right it's
amrand you're never going to be
surprised by something in the third act
and so there's a real overlap for that
that i found and so one of the things
that i've been trying to do uh given how
polarized i have found discourse to be
and how i found myself moving between
vastly different worlds
is to try to commit myself to ending um
or contributing to ending polarizing
discourse uh and so part of that is i've
been focused on trying to rebrand the
the democratic party uh working with a
lot of different candidates and entities
in an effort to get away from from
gridlock and more towards solutions um i
have a view that's a lot like jonathan
height who you've interviewed at length
um who i think gives a great
description of the need and necessity
for both conservatives and liberals in
that
you know conservatives like walls around
things right they like walls around
gender they like walls around countries
uh build a wall as sort of a brilliant
republican slogan and the job of of
liberals is to say hang on a minute if
that wall is too impenetrable
you're not going to have new ideas and
people and then we'll stagnate and die
and so for me and you and i've talked
before about how it's also the case for
inventors and entrepreneurs
who kind of create things which tends to
be more of a liberal leaning but if you
want them run effectively often you need
conservative managers to come in
and so
i want there to be stronger parties on
both sides i mean i want there to be
better discourse i think if there's a
stronger republican party it makes the
democratic party have to raise their
game and come up with solutions and out
of the one thing i will say that has
been common of everyone who i talked to
is nobody is thrilled with the level of
political discourse right now
also there's a couple of things there
that are really interesting i mean you
talk about the necessity for
uh high quality representation on both
sides of the political uh
um political what do you call that
continuum let's say
right and and there are really powerful
temperamental and philosophical reasons
for that so you know you mentioned that
the liberal types tend to be
entrepreneurs and creators and uh
conservative types tend to be managers
and administrators so that's that's
pretty well documented in the
psychological literature but you see
echoes of that and you you mentioned the
border issue as well because of course
to categorize things we have to put
boundaries around them but boundaries
can artificially separate and and make
things stagnant as well so we have to
have a continual discussion about
exactly where the boundary should be
drawn without ever also presuming that
we should just do away with boundaries
all together because that does away with
category and then with regards to
hierarchies well
you know it seems to be the job of the
right wing to
put forward the proposition that
hierarchies are necessary from an
organizational perspective so
if a bunch of people decide to go do
something of value let's say it's of
collective value as well as individual
value then inevitably when they operate
cooperatively and competitively they're
going to produce a hierarchy and the
hierarchy is actually a tool to
accomplish that task in in the social
arena but the problem with that is that
a hierarchy can become over rigid and
corrupt and it can dispossess people
without without that dispossession being
a necessary function of the task that
the hierarchy is attempting to perform
right what's that it's always both right
i mean it's always that we needed to
organize and they're always our
inequities but a result of it that's
right and the thing that i have found is
that when people lock in the political
conversations from one side or the other
it becomes all or nothing and for me
nothing gets accomplished in all or
nothing and so to straw man
you know democrats that all of them just
want to tear down the whole system and
you know those are some of the loud
voices on twitter isn't helpful any more
than the claim that republicans have no
interest whatsoever in the people who
are dispossessed and so a lot of what's
important is to look at
you know
conservatives who are
you know thoughtful it's not like they
love the fact that people are
dispossessed so the question becomes how
do we all help that and how do we
actually have a discussion and how do we
how do we get away from the fact that
compromise
towards solutions is somehow a betrayal
that if you compromise anything from the
furthest extreme you're sort of
betraying your own ideology and your own
people yeah well i think partly you do
that by focusing on specific problems
instead of broader ideological solutions
and that's so part of what we're trying
to discuss today and to contribute to is
the the re-centralization let's say of
the political parties and also to make a
case for the necessity of intelligent
discourse knowing that people on both
sides of the political spectrum have
something intelligent to say
so the conservatives have every reason
to
put forward the proposition that
hierarchies are both inevitable and
useful
but also to keep firmly in mind that
they can become corrupt and that they do
tend to dispossess and the liberals have
any every reason to keep in mind that
hierarchies are absolutely necessary in
order to get things done but that
the dispossessed need of voice so that
the system remains both permeable and
fair
and it's really necessary for both sides
to have some uh respect for the position
of the alternative of the alternative
temperamental type let's say well that's
where we have to meet in in rational
sort of enlightenment discourse or else
we can't win you know right you talked a
lot about the big the big five
personality traits and the ways that it
orients differently in politics so it's
like liberals are higher in empathy
right in higher and openness that's why
a lot of artists you find are um tend to
be liberal you know at least the good
ones like we have bruce springsteen and
on the other side it's hard for for for
president trump to fill up an arena with
people who who are the artists of
a certain caliber
and
you know it doesn't mean that that
higher empathy is better and i think
often when liberals are talking they're
trying to push through only empathy and
higher empathy and they're trying to
educate people in the higher empathy
well it's a fixed psychological trait
and the other thing is you know
republicans or or conservatives tend to
be higher in conscientiousness and
conscientiousness codes for a bunch of
things that are really useful you know
codes for better health better finances
more stable marriages and longer
lifespan so one of the things when i'm
advising you know democrats is like you
can't if you you have to win an argument
on the merits you have to make a better
argument if you're losing people you
can't just go to them and say be more
empathetic that's not an argument right
it's it's like going to
president clinton and saying can't you
just be an introvert these are sort of
fixed traits and the other thing is is a
lot of conservatives are doing fine over
there with their stable marriages and
longer lives well and the empathy issue
is interesting as well because it's easy
for that to be regarded reflexively as a
virtue
but an excess of pity let's say can be
destructive there's a whole
psychoanalytic literature on the
negative consequences of of fostering
over dependence let's say and that's a
real problem and there is a managerial
literature too that suggests that less
agreeable managers do better as well as
less agreeable people in general having
higher incomes because they're better at
bargaining for themselves so it is
really necessary to give some
consideration to the fact that each of
these temperaments has it marked
advantages and disadvantages and a
proper niche where it can function and
and other places where it actually
constitutes a problem well that's where
we have to rise above ourselves and meet
like where do we meet we meet in freedom
of speech there's a reason it's the
first amendment you know if i was dumb
enough to be a single issue voter that
would be my single issue because part of
it is
as as a classical liberal i tend to
approach things i have a strong amount
of empathy but i also realize that
that's not a trait that i can map onto
everybody else when i'm having a
discussion that i have to actually meet
and make arguments
for people who who approach the world in
different ways and have different kinds
of successes to make higher
conscientious arguments in a way that
appeals more broadly and i mean that's
free marketplace of ideas we have to
meet and figure out and discuss these
matters and if we're not doing it in
words we're doing with fists
the other problem with agreeableness
let's say an empathy is that
the the the empathetic identification
tends to make the person who's
experiencing it feel immediately
virtuous because they're on the side of
the weaker party let's say and there's
obviously some utility in that but it's
not really it doesn't come
with a set of
solutions to complex problems
you know it seems to me that
agreeableness is a pretty good virtue
for small units like the family where
egalitarian distribution is of extreme
importance but it doesn't seem to work
very well at at higher levels of
complexity so for example it's
conscientiousness that predicts
workplace proficiency
you know it's the second best predictor
after iq agreeableness is actually
somewhat negatively correlated unless
unless the domain has to do with with
direct personal care and so i don't
think agreeableness scales very well
which is why conscientiousness has to
enter into the picture
yeah i view it as like a very helpful
motivator for myself i look at a problem
my approach tends to be empathy for
people who have been left out or have
been who don't have the right end of the
dominance hierarchy um and and for me
it's a motivator to look at actual
solutions and problems and issues and
there's a lot of real concrete things
that can be attacked but if you don't
attack them from a perspective that's
morally condescending you can actually
get done well it also
it's also very helpful to increase the
resolution of the problem right and and
to stop trying to solve every problem
with one with one brush stroke most
things are really complicated so
intelligent political discourse should
involve decomposing a problem like
poverty which isn't our problem but a
set of a thousand problems into each of
those thousand problems and then trying
to generate creative solutions to each
of them and then to test them and so
the resolution of the of the discussion
has to be increased and one of the
things that you and i had talked about
was the possibility that these
longer-form the longer-form discourse
um avenues that are available on the new
media like what we're doing right now
might enable us to identify and promote
politicians who are capable of high
resolution discussion who have real
solutions to real problems instead of
having to compress everything into a six
second sound bite well the other thing
that i'm finding really heartening is a
lot of the candidates that i am working
with interacting with and at this point
that's in the hundreds
are very focused on actual solutions and
i'm trying to get a handle on
you know the cultural conversation
whatever the hell that is
it benefits by blowing the extremes up
and it feels like that's almost all that
we're hearing about and when i'm dealing
with actual candidates a lot of them are
dealing with anti-corruption healthcare
jobs and education like they're aware
that that isn't the play and so there's
this amplifying effect and then we have
a lot of sort of like this cultural
conversation about the cultural
conversation that things become very
kind of meta and the level that
candidates are operating at and the
level that people are you know i'm
dealing a lot with candidates in
different states people are having a
hard time right now and they need
hardcore solutions and they actually
don't give a about everyone on
twitter and facebook who's you know
preaching everyone hasn't already
unfriended them they need solutions they
need a government that's functional they
need uh they want more transparency and
lack of corruption there's a very common
set of things that that govern people
but there's a sort of amplified effect
from the extremes of the party that are
are gathering the the attention and the
biggest tool that we have in a democracy
in some ways is our attention and where
we focus
and if that's being hijacked by
you know conversations and
straw men i mean i would love to engage
with
with reasonable
you know republicans a lot of whom are
my friends and are my colleagues to say
look i know we can go and push
everything to extremes and fight and
debate and score points but like you
don't like some of this anymore
than i do like what's an actual
conversation from our different
perspectives assuming i don't have all
the answers that we can come up with
certain solutions that's going to take
care of people who are not doing as well
you know who are not doing as well who
are not keeping up with the economy
because that's not good for anybody
that's not a game that is iterable
across multiple games and generations if
more and more people are struggling more
and more that ain't good for anybody
even the people at the top so how do we
seek to kind of balance that out for
people who don't have a fair shot and
don't have
even from a conservative perspective you
could say well how do we stabilize the
hierarchy so the tendency for or the
multiple hierarchies for the tendency so
that the tendency for people to stack up
at the bottom doesn't become so extreme
that the entire system starts to shake
and and tremble which obviously isn't
good for anyone at all we're seeing a
lot of shaking and trembling i mean i
think a lot of people in the last
election did not feel heard or seen or
represented in the choices of candidates
and a lot of people are like i don't
care what it is it's not going to be
business as usual right so the solution
isn't in my estimation to denigrate
people who chose to vote for president
trump i think
the solution is to talk about the fact
that we need to do better if we want to
promote a if the democrats want to
promote a viable alternative we have to
do better with what our messaging is we
have to do better on messages that are
anti-corruption we have to make a better
argument yeah well the thing is you know
i was on bill marshall a while back and
a lot of the panelists on his show were
really taking pot shots at the trump
supporters and and
you know with the typical sort of
pejoratives that are labeled at or
leveled at them and i thought that was
extremely dangerous because they're
basically dissing let's say to use a
terrible cliche about 50 of the american
population and the same percentage
that's been voting republican for about
20 years and to just out of hand dismiss
your the people who are voting
differently than you as somehow
primitive or primordial or foolish or
are ill-advised is very very dangerous
and also more than that it's also an
abdication of responsibility because
the the republicans might have won the
last election or trump might have won
the last election but certainly the
democrats lost the last election and so
i would have i thought that their
discourse would have been a lot more
productive if they would have focused on
the failings of the democratic party and
that's also a lot more useful because if
you can figure out why you didn't
succeed even though it was very close
election if you can figure out what
mistakes you made then you could rectify
it
i mean that's exactly along the lines of
the things that you and i talk about at
length which is personal accountability
it's like you getting a fight with your
wife or your husband
is the best thing to do to point out the
50 or 80 or 90 where they screwed up or
to actually reflect and think about
whatever percent it is or whatever
number that you can do something better
that's actually within your control
and so for me that's a scalable notion
you know i have so many friends too wide
and varied and smart who voted for trump
to dismiss them all as idiots it's it's
a very you can't denigrate it and plus
we're married to them that's 50 years
49.9 of our population we are married to
them and we have to figure out how to
talk and to come up with solutions
that that make sense and that everybody
can and so for me a lot of it is to look
at what the impulse was that was
underlying that and to figure out where
democrats can be better at
seeing and hearing people and furthering
arguments in ways that feel legitimate
and connect with people and to figure
out what the messaging is and you always
clean up your side of the house first
and it doesn't mean that there's there's
a number of policies that i'm highly
critical of of president trump it
doesn't mean that i denigrate his
followers or the people who voted for
him or that i will dismiss any
tendencies that they might have had or
hesitations that they might have had
about voting otherwise yeah well the
right message should be something like
um not so much why
your opponent is worse but by why you're
better why your solutions are better why
why why why the grass is greener on your
side of the fence why there's less
corruption occurring under your watch
and
and also marketing the fact that the
solutions that you have are both
reasonable and practical i mean that
does require a more elevated form of
political discourse and it would be
really nice if that could be facilitated
by these by these long forms that are
available online we hear the refrain all
the time of like the democrats don't
have a message like saying that
president trump is awful is not a
message and i've been i've been really
heartened with the conversations that
i'm having with candidates right now
that there's a huge focus on kitchen
table issues there's a huge focus on
trying to tackle healthcare and
education and jobs in ways that are more
innovative when you talk to the actual
candidates who i want to start to pull
into more and more conversations i have
an enormous amount of of optimism and
the other thing is
is your real money where your mouth is
stance against corruption and there's
some there's something called the
disclose act that a lot of democrats are
working on which is fully disclosing all
of your donors you know releasing taxes
um taking a pledge against no dark money
there's a whole number of different
resolutions you know
fighting voter suppression and that
means whether we lose or not it's not
about fighting voter suppression to sort
of tilt the vote in a direction it's
like we need the right to win elections
or lose elections fairly
and so there's a lot of positions that
are being put forth right now that i
feel are really heartening including a
very strong anti-corruption stance
because
you can't you have to clean up what your
side is and in this wave of candidates
that i'm looking at
it's been really
impressive to me how they're starting to
further and articulate what the pop what
the argument can be from that side and i
think that's where we can also start to
find common ground
to talk about the corruption i mean
there's a lot of republicans who aren't
thrilled with the level of discourse
right now
one of the things that struck me when
i've been talking to you lately is when
we've been talking about what happened
with the democratic party is also the
idea that the radicals the identity
politics types managed to take over the
narrative to a large degree partly
because the extremism is more attractive
let's say among a dying mainstream media
it's click-baity and easy to attract
attention to and loud and and cinematic
and all of those things but also that
the centrist democrats seem to have lost
faith in their central narrative or
perhaps have failed to to produce one
over the last 15 years and that left a
void into which the extremist narrative
the oppressor oppressive oppressor
oppression narrative let's say or
pressure victim narrative has been able
to slide in and dominate because of that
void and so that's another thing that
needs to be seriously addressed it's
like the center has lost its narrative
and
and and and that's something i'd like to
see the democrats uh deal with now in it
in in
in the first ad that you generated
you had a farmer talk if i remember
correctly you had a farmer talk about
success and about what that might mean
if you could attain it individually
i think where we have fallen down
as democrats and and where we are now
reorienting is is is the discussion of
aspirational values meaning
is it a rigged game like we can
absolutely point to things that are
disadvantages you know but to say it's a
rig game it's a regain the thing that we
have to say is all that we're in favor
of are fair rules at the starting gate
and if you work harder if you're an
innovator if you bust your ass good on
you like go buy a mansion in three cars
you know go start a second business we
have to be rewarding of success and
speaking of people's aspirations and you
know we talk a lot about income
inequality and the problem with that is
what's the opposite of that is income
equality well nobody wants that if you
look at the average salaries and incomes
of people in the senate and congress
they're doing just fine they don't want
that either and so for me i think it's
much more powerful to talk about income
and justice
because it means that people have a fair
shot at the starting gate and then they
can differentiate themselves by their
own you know abilities and their own
willingness to work and for me it's
about the starting gate and making sure
that we look at things that are there um
yeah well and also that the emphasis
that you just placed on rewarding actual
achievement we also have to be in a
situation where we can admit that at
least one of the factors that
differentiates people as they move up
competence hierarchies and we have to
admit that some of the hierarchies that
exist are actually based on competence
and not merely on oppression is the
amount of effort they put into things
and you know that's become that's become
an anathematic uh
proposition on many university campuses
where you're not allowed in fact to
state that
hard work that some of the people who
have made it have done done it as a
consequence of working extra hard
because i guess that undermines the
narrative that the whole game is rigged
and the truth of the matter is the game
is partly rigged
like all games always are and that is
unfortunate but we can't throw the whole
damn game out because it's partly rigged
unless you think you can put in place a
game that isn't going to be rigged and
good luck with that it's yeah i mean
there is a very interesting uh interview
between eric weinstein and ben shapiro
on the podcast and what's so interesting
is they're from completely opposite
sides of the spectrum i think doesn't
eric define himself as a socialist
well he's certainly on the left yeah i
mean so but you had them discussed and
it was very very civil discourse and i
think eric can do a much better job than
i can of discussing the ways in which
the issue isn't that there's a dominance
hierarchy and that people differentiate
themselves based on their hard work the
issue is sort of what we've seen with
the separation of the working class and
people at the very very top you know he
points to a lot of trends about what's
happening with workers wages you know
ceo a few decades ago made 30 times the
average worker now it's at 300. it's not
about overall people doing well if
there's an increasing exponential
separation between you know working
people
and and people who are at the top and i
think that's the skew that's problematic
and the fact of the matter is rather
than pushing away
and you know we can talk a little bit
also about you know
conservatives like ben but rather than
sort of denigrating it there's a lot of
good brains on both sides of the fence
and like wouldn't it be absolutely
lovely if we had reasonable
conversations about what we all want to
do about that rather than the position
having to be
income equality versus you know only
self-reliance and put yourself up by
your bootstraps because there's some
people who can't do that there are some
fundamental problems with the system
that's leading to people having a lot
harder time and everyone agrees with
that and if we can talk about the
details you know it's sort of like when
we talk about universal health care i
feel like you come in the door and the
minute you say it people are foreign
against
and for me there's a lot of other
arguments to make it's like look we
already have universal health care in
this country it's called emergency rooms
it's unamerican and wrong to let people
die on the streets we don't do that but
if people are uninsured the hospital
passes on the cost to insurance
companies who raise our premiums so the
average cost of an emergency room visit
the united states is one thousand two
hundred thirty three dollars the average
cost of a vaccination is nineteen
dollars we're all paying for it anyways
and there's also a lot less risk of
public health hazards and other things
if we can figure out a way to come up
with a medical system that people are
getting the care that they want
preventative care is infinitely cheaper
than trying to play catch up in
emergency rooms and if you don't just
walk in the door and say i'm for
universal healthcare i'm opposed to
universal healthcare because a lot of
people say look i was out of work and
having a hard time i had to figure out
paying my own health care we have to
frame it in a way of saying this is good
for the robustness of the whole
community and i think there's a lot of
arguments and discussions of from both
sides that we need we need all those
brains pulling together
and it's one of the things is i'm
watching a lot of the idw stuff
i would love to see increasingly
increasing conversations like the one
that eric and ben had where there's two
people from the opposite side who are
engaging very reasonably and seeing each
other's points and trying to figure out
what skills they can bring from their
respective sides of of the proverbial
aisle
so you see you think you see within the
democratic party an attempt at least to
increase the resolution of the
discussion and to move away from the
more polarizing discourse you see that
starting to develop
absolutely so tell me some of the
concrete things you've seen
i mean you know i've been meeting with a
lot of candidates i i found there's a
candidate who i really like called
joseph cops running in texas who's a you
know 20-year in the army he's a ranger i
believe he is a bronze star he's a
graduate of you know harvard's kennedy
school as a professor at west point
and what was amazing with him is like he
was talking about universal health care
he started his own business a private
business that led to tons of jobs and
he's this incredible person and he made
an argument in a way i haven't ever
thought about it when he's talking about
healthcare he was like look i have my
healthcare from the army for life that
allowed me to take a risk
and to go out entrepreneurially to start
a company that then led to tons and tons
of jobs
you know you know there's evidence in
canada our rate of entrepreneurial
development in canada per capita is
actually slightly higher than it is in
the us and analysis has indicated that
one of the reasons for that is the
provision of universal health care well
people can take entrepreneurial risks in
canada without losing their their
fundamental safety net so you can make a
conservative argument for the provision
of a certain level of of underlying
security let's say
right and it was it was a great argument
for me i mean the other thing is i'm
seeing a lot of candidates who are
democrats who are very upfront with
their support for the second amendment
and it's like look the second amendment
is an amendment you can't just get rid
of an amendment and i know that as a
classical liberal when people come after
freedom of speech
i get really pissed right and people who
are who are who are living in different
regions in different states that have
different cultures when they hear people
start to attack the second amendment or
or when it's global where it's all or
nothing if there's an inherent threat
that comes with that and a lot of it for
me is to look at and go look every
amendment has certain
limitations on it right so you can't
stand up on an airplane and scream that
you have a bomb you can't threaten the
president united states that you're
going to kill him the first amendment we
have parameters around it we already
have them in place around the second
amendment everybody knows you can't own
a bazooka everyone knows you can't own a
dirty bomb so instead of coming in
and sort of threatening people in their
way of life if they have handguns if
they're hunting if they are weapons
collectors
if we can boil the resolution down and
say we're already having every amendment
we have or the first and second
amendment we have certain limitations
that we've placed on it for the safety
of the community so how about if we just
talk about violent history checks let's
just talk about that one piece so 90 of
americans are in favor of that and 73 of
the nra and so to have a candidate stand
up and say
you know i love the first amendment i
fully support the second amendment
believe me i have a lot of friends who
are army rangers green berets and seals
i know that culture well
and rather than having some sort of
frontal attack on it to sort of say well
what's reasonable you can't yell fire in
a crowded theater how about if we only
discuss that and i'm standing with
ninety percent of americans and 73 of
nra members it's a much more respectful
conversation and it's a much more
solution-based concept it's also a
humble humbler conversation because it
it it requires a certain amount of
appreciation for incremental change
right because
it's very ego inflating to do a great
thing to make a massive change and much
less so to work in the background to
make a small change but small changes
are solid and they tend not to produce
terrible negative consequences and
to
and to work incrementally is to work
realistically and properly and i would
also say meaningfully
yeah and that that's another
that's another element that needs to be
introduced back into the discourse is
like well
why don't we
you know the people who established the
american
american system were incrementalists
fundamentally and they knew perfectly
well that we had a flawed system that
was always going to be flawed and the
best we could do is was tinker away at
it incrementally and that's a really
lovely sentiment i think it's very it's
very mature and wise to understand that
what you're working on is like a highway
it always needs repair there's always
going to be construction on it there's
always going to be blockages on it
because it needs to be maintained and
updated but you don't you don't you
don't scrap the whole thing with every
move and part of the problem with the
discourse now too is that
every issue becomes code for an
ideological position like i have a real
hard time with um all the
environmentalist noise that i hear on
the mainstream media in particular
because i always see it as code for a
very fundamental anti-capitalist ethos
and so i can't separate the damn wheat
from the chaff i mean i know because
i've read a lot about ecological issues
that there are foolish things that
people are doing in the world for a
variety of reasons like overfishing is a
real catastrophe and so is so is deep
ocean trolley as far as i'm concerned
but when i read general environmentalist
claims and these include climate change
claims i can't separate it from a
fundamental anti-capitalist ethos and so
i can't decide i can never decide
whether i can trust the the information
yeah and there's that russoian underlay
too that like man is bad and nature is
good right that's not a rallying cry to
say let me pitch original sin to you
right that argument is to say what are
short-term effective gains that can be
made in additional middle and long-term
in business for clean rivers and clean
oceans and for fishing industries
um and also to talk about the things
we've accomplished i mean we closed the
ozone hole and companies didn't hold a
lot of business there are actually
solutions
um you know we've basically eliminated
polio from the face of the earth there's
entrepreneurial and innovative solutions
for things that can also be pro-business
yes and we've reforested the northern
hemisphere you know there's more forest
in the northern hemisphere than there
was a hundred years ago i mean so you
said this thing about about you know
incremental change and it's another
thing i've been thinking about a lot
which is when we walk in the door and
say i'm for gun control or
i'm pro-life in in every circumstance or
or um
you know to come in with an absolute
position
one of the things that's really tricky
is if you're not willing to have a
conversation if you're not willing to
see ground
there's no terms under which you feel
that the the negotiation or compromise
can be satisfied
and that gets really dangerous and it's
funny because it's something that i
always advocate for when people talk
about um sort of a broad sweeping
systemic problem or justice the problem
is is it doesn't boil it down a level of
resolution that you can get traction
from all the people that you need
because people feel like well what's the
solution if the solution is to throw
everything away positive and negative
and change everything they're not going
to do it and it's a problem we saw with
occupy wall street um and you know it
sort of spread from generalized
corruption and incidentally they were
targeting sort of the banks and the
bigger systems almost more than they
were the government who was allowing a
lot of it but then as it kept rolling
into issue after issue after issue it
starts to get very complex of like well
if we concede and make changes are there
any terms under which you'll be
satisfied and i think that's a that's
one of the aspects of coming in on
positions of like thrower against
universal health care right pro or
against the second amendment there's no
ground to be had there because
everyone's just digging in their heels
and i feel like it's also a bit of a
product of
uh social media and the fact that we've
all been sort of infantilized to sort of
these likes and dopamine hits that keep
driving virtue signaling and that goes
for both sides it goes for both sides if
you can get a real slam or dig in on
your opponent then good for you and
meanwhile in the middle there's a ton of
americans there's a ton of kids uh in
education systems that need real
solutions and it doesn't matter how much
we're signaling what our beliefs are in
our respective bubbles it doesn't come
down the real solution well it's also
much more difficult to generate real
solutions because it means you actually
have to have some domain knowledge and
it isn't obvious for example that
the classic
forms of media that politicians have
used to interact with the populace have
rewarded high resolution knowledge you
know because it becomes
well it's easy for it to get tangled up
in the details for that kind of
discussion to get tangled up in the
details but these longer form
conversations might allow people to
unpack some of that in a more
intelligent way well yeah for instance
there was a great discussion between
dave rubin and ben shapiro at one point
talking about abortion and they're on
opposite sides of it and what was really
interesting was it was civil and there
was no denigration of the opposing side
and also was saying look i don't have an
exact answer of when
for me it becomes uncomfortable like
there is some point that that it moves
from something that that is
um
into a point that he's not comfortable
with abortion there's a certain date
that that would happen or a certain
point in trimesters
and so it's
and it's hard there aren't super clear
and easy answers and you know ben has a
different position obviously he's much
more conservative on that front but
that's a position it's weird i have a
lot of friends who were born in
christians and it's like that's a
position
you can't just dismiss like you have to
talk about it like that's a human
position for people who have that belief
i mean so for me what it really comes
down to
when there's these sort of different
positions on stuff that's really
fundamental for people is to say look i
don't we i feel like democrats have to
talk about ways that are more humanizing
which is i don't actually know what i
would do in that circumstance if my wife
um
you know was was was pregnant or a
girlfriend
like it's a really hard choice it's not
something that's just flippant of like
oh it's a cluster of cells and it
carries no emotional weight that's i
just don't find that to be true but for
me there's a certain point where i don't
think that's ever true for anyone who
has an experience like that right i feel
the right way to approach him
well i think that the answer is like
look i don't know what i would do i
don't claim to have all the answers
morally the one thing that i believe is
i don't want the government coming into
your house and into your bedroom and
telling your wife or you what to do like
that's something i feel like it's so
deeply personal and sometimes all you
have are shitty choices and choices that
aren't good and the flip side for me is
i don't know what the alternative is
when we're really talking with specifics
i don't know what government mandated
pregnancy looks like so if a daughter or
a niece who's you know 18 is pregnant
and doesn't want to have a child i don't
know what the solution is to that
like how does the government then
mandate that and oversee that
and so these are conversations that that
you know i think are
legitimate conversations to be had
but but from a position of respect
rather than
you know sort of slogans or the fact
that the people who are pro-life are
anti-anti-women
because there's a lot of women who i
know who have you know deeply held
pro-life positions i think it has to be
a bit of a conversation that for me i
feel like
these are really personal choices i have
a strong libertarian reaction to it and
i also don't understand what the
solution is going to be
if that does become something that
somebody doesn't want to have a child i
don't understand how the government
mandates that and what that looks like
for those nine months
and so you know it's not an approach
that's dismissive that's all or nothing
it's an approach of having a
conversation about you know differing
values and we have different values and
we have to figure out how to
how to talk about them in ways that
aren't dehumanizing
so what do you think what's a good plan
for the next few months what are you
going to try to do
well i have a number of plans i mean one
of them is to keep um democrats focused
on
nuts and bolts issues i also really um
there's a lot of republican voices that
i think are really important i mean i
really like uh evan mcmullen i really
like rick wilson there's a number of
commentators who have been
been really interesting and compelling i
listen to the broad spectrum of
everything i wake up every morning and
and also read the drudge report and
watch fox news to have an understanding
of
of what opposing narratives are so that
i can i can understand the full sort of
spectrum on what's bothering people what
isn't
and hero shapiro is a really good voice
as far as i'm concerned because he's as
intelligent an articulator of the social
conservative position as you could hope
for and so he's a great whetstone
against which democrats could sharpen
their knives well because if they can if
they can confront him in a reasonable
argument successfully then they've
already got the argument down because
and here's the thing with ben he's got a
great brain i actually would like it if
he was playing less defense
and actually could be engaged the way
that eric has to be like look what is
your what are your solutions and
thoughts on this front there are some
things he said that i deeply disagree
with like i don't believe that all trans
people are are mentally ill he has some
positions but nothing that i've seen
indicates to me that he's someone who
can't conceivably be reasoned with he's
also pointed out in places where he
believes he's screwed up he's written a
whole articles about reversing his
position on things or stuff he said that
was dumb
and
well that's that's his words not mine
but um
you know it's like the ralph waldo
emerson a foolish a foolish consistency
is the hob goblin of little minds it's
like how many of us have a completely
consistent set of ideas and so i feel
like with ben
and there was that big issue where mark
duplass came out and sort of said well
why don't we listen to him and there was
a big uproar and then he apologized and
i think that's an interesting thing to
discuss because from my perspective you
have three views if you're liberal on
venture hero one is that he's an
alt-right nazi which i don't believe i
don't believe um that he's so far all
right i should say fascist not nazi
because he's old yeah and that's we need
to define what the hell the alt-right is
too you know the alt-right is basically
a cover story for white supremacy and
for an ethno-nationalist state and to
target everybody who's conservative as
an alt-right figure which is something
that's happened to me repeatedly is
absolutely counterproductive right
because especially right now you have
all our lectures on your opposition it's
all right i mean it's very easily
disprovable but with ben like let's say
for the sake of argument that that's who
he is
which i don't believe
why would you not want to pay attention
or follow him or keep an eye on him or
know what he's saying it's not like he's
some crackpot you know he's someone
who's very influential and has a lot of
followers so even if it's the case which
i don't believe it is i don't understand
how
not paying any attention to what's going
on with him is helpful um you know i i
gotta say one of the highlights of the
error that i think apple and facebook
and spotify and so forth just made with
alex jones you know because they think
they banned alex jones but that isn't
what happened what happened was they
pushed his millions of followers
underground that was a very bad idea and
they're making a murder out of him in a
certain way oh and they're justifying
you know he's a little on the paranoid
side let's say he's a real conspiracy
theorist and the best the worst thing
you can possibly do to someone who's
paranoid is to generate a conspiracy to
take him out well and my revival is the
best thing you can do when alex jones
has said virtually nothing that i agree
with on any front is to give him as much
air time and as much rope as possible or
to or at least allow him access to that
in the same way that everyone else has
access to it you know because like i i
don't watch alex jones but there are a
number of people on the right that i
keep an eye on are the farther right
because i want to see what they're up to
you know and and as soon as that becomes
impossible then you have no idea what
those people are up to and how the hell
are you supposed to be able to deal with
it if you can't figure out what it is
well we're not watching it like i'm a
big fan like i'm i'm a big fan of the
aspect of the aclu that was the skokie
aspect which was we show up if nazis
want to march
right and we will protect their right to
peacefully march and it's like i have
people who i despise
it's like get out there at a point
you'll be crushed by the free
marketplace of ideas i have that belief
at a point
but you have to allow for it and the
more that we murder and shut down
we don't know how many people were
watching alex jones to keep an eye on
him
right you know i don't imagine it was a
tremendous number of people but it
wasn't none
right
well look you and i have talked about
this one of the highlights of my
undergraduate
years
um was when the bell curve came out and
there was a debate at the kennedy center
and dick hernstein who i had as a
professor had passed away and charles
murray was sort of left to defend it
against stephen j gould and it was a
very high level of discourse and henry
lewis gates
gave the introduction things were very
very heated on campus because of the
claims about racial differences in iq it
was a very flashpoint issue and skip
gates gave a spectacular introduction
and he said look there's a lot of
sentiments roiling around this issue and
the best possible thing that we can do
is to dispute and defend and dismiss the
aspects of this that aren't correct here
openly and publicly
and there was a big debate a lot of the
student groups stood up and walked out
after that entry from one of the you
know
amazing intellectual minds uh
of of you know in the country and so i
just went down and sat in the front row
because people it it piled out it's like
i wanted to hear the debate i wanted to
hear the sites from from from all
different arenas and it was totally
totally captivating but his point was
once if someone's a crackpot and they
don't have any followers and it's it's a
stupid racist bellowing things it's fine
to ignore people there's a certain point
where when it's dick hernstein and
charles murray there's a point where
that needs to be debated publicly and
openly and the fact that the chair of
the african american studies department
was advocating for that to me i thought
was really important and should be
heated that we need these things these
debates to be had and the aspects that
are
that are incorrect need to be
disproved uh in an enlightenment way in
in a very intense and public way and so
that's something that i've always sort
of held to is i don't you know and i'm
look i mean there's also part of this
about it's sort of a toughness argument
my grandfather
went down during the civil rights
movement he was a jewish lawyer from
manhattan and went down in the deep
south to stick up for
uh to to represent african americans
who'd been convicted of crimes against
white women there's one case in
particular that was totally ridiculous
and he went down and people tried to run
his car off a cliff and kill him and so
part of it for me too is like
i'm from that mindset of like tough
liberals who want to who actually can
stand up we need we need people to be
toughened on all sides of discourse
and i feel like you know when people
were burning copies of ulysses i feel
like we're supposed to be the ones with
the fire hoses putting out the fires
we're supposed to be the ones who can be
really tough and stand our ground and if
we can't do that if we're gonna duck
from
those fights and that hardening of a of
uh of a sort of intense positive um
really tough version of what the points
are that we're arguing then it's not
it's not a legitimate case we need to be
that's who we need it's a tough time
when we need tough discourse
yeah well that and that is exactly why
you should seek out the most articulate
exponents of your of your opponent's
position you know i just had that
experience talking with sam harris and
we talked for 10 hours and you know
there are things we agree about one of
the most fundamental things is that both
sam and i are concerned that
our ethical structures
it would be better if our ethical
structures were grounded in something
that was self-evidently solid and so he
wants to do that he wants to ground
ethics in the realm of fact and i can i
can understand that it's it's a
perfectly valid desire i don't believe
it's possible in the way that he sees it
as possible and we talked about that a
lot but i learned a tremendous amount as
a consequence of discussing
things with him over a 10-hour period
because he really pushed me
yeah
you need to be pushed man because
absolutely you need people to pick all
kinds of holes and you need to go in
understanding that you might not have
all the answers well that you don't have
all the answers and so for you with that
what i think is interesting is
your approach to that is to ground
things in an evolutionary model which i
think is a pretty good bedrock right
i mean that's been your sort of approach
to this is to talk about like a sort of
archetypal and evolutionary underlay but
sam's unbelievably articulate and sharp
i mean i had a pleasure having dinner
with you and him and douglas murray in
london and
it's it's a vibrant respectful
sometimes disagreeable mode of
conversation that's incredibly fruitful
it's awesome it's also um stressful as
hell you know because you can definitely
get put on the spot and have your
cherished assumptions undermined and as
well as look like a fool because right
you know some of the time even if you
have an argument well thought through in
that kind of discourse you don't have it
immediately at hand you forget about it
and then you know you it doesn't appear
as if you're a fool and so you put a lot
on the line in the discussion like that
but what you do is at least no one's
paying attention to any of this jordan
so yeah
yeah yeah for you to have a moment where
sam harris goes ha gotcha right right so
well so one
so there's a lot of proposals that that
i'll get or that are that are floated
let's say there's an economic idea that
somebody has in in my group that wants
to be passed on
the first thing that i do with it is i
send it to i have a friend who's a
really sharp libertarian i have a friend
who's a hardcore kind of wall street
republican
um and i have another friend who's who's
kind of a big money person so they
represent sort of the different polls of
economic policy from the things that
some of the policies that might be
interesting to me the first thing i do
is send it to all them and go poke as
many holes in this as you possibly can
and tell me what all the blind spots are
and that's not only for me to cover all
those arguments it's also for me to be
able to learn and see if there's a
better approach to it if it's
fundamentally flawed and then certainly
if i'm going to advocate something
that's a new policy i'm not strong on
economics i mean it's probably my
spot but it's to sort of know if we're
going to advocate it what are all the
pitfalls we're falling into and what are
we potentially missing
and i find very few people are taking an
approach like this and it's one of the
things that's i think is exciting it's
funny with the idw has this sort of
fear of an alt-right overlay but the
majority of you guys skew pretty liberal
i mean if you look at joe if you look at
dave certainly
um if you look at eric and brett i mean
it's it's got more of a skew but what's
nice is ideas can be parsed in a way
where as much as it is embarrassing when
you're put on the spot and you're wrong
no one's looking to twist the knife you
know what i mean everyone's kind of
saying yeah i disagree with this it's
it's disagreeable it's high
disagreeableness but it's respectful
yeah well it's also best based at least
to some degree on trust
you know if i can assume that you're
different than me temperamentally but
that you're actually striving towards
the truth then we can have a discussion
and i certainly feel that with sam
yes i mean i believe that i believe i
believe that he's an honest person
and you know or i believe that he's as
honest as me let's say which is more to
the point right because well maybe an
honest person is too high a barrier for
anyone to actually achieve given all of
our faults but i don't believe there's
any evidence that he's striving with
less intensity towards the truth than i
am
right
well to get back to i think the furthest
right in the group is clearly ben you
know and to get back to that point it's
like there's sort of three approaches
either he's a horrible human
and he's a hardcore alt-righter in which
case if you believe that why from a sun
tzu perspective art of war would you not
want to know your enemy and figure it
out yeah or he's somebody who has views
and ideologies i disagree with him on on
a number of fronts you know
but he's somebody who is who is
interested in the truth and is willing
to admit when he has gone too far
or not gone too far that's the wrong
phrase he's willing to admit missteps
that he perceives that he's made and has
also
taken new information and it's like i'd
love to actually have a discussion with
him about something a discussion not a
debate because he's a world-class
debater he would probably obliterate me
but but an actual meaningful discussion
about some of the stuff where i see
there to be differences
well i think he's i think he might be in
for that like you and i have discussed
the possibility of
finding
high-resolution intelligent centrist
democrats and getting some of these idw
people to interact with them yeah and so
you know that looks like it's a real
possibility and be interesting to see
what that would do to the political
discourse and i guess this is a step on
that a step in that direction i talked
to
bannon to
dave rubin and
to
joe uh or to um to sam
and uh
you know hypothetically they're they're
at least willing to look into this as a
possibility and it would be very
interesting as well
go ahead
go ahead sorry oh well it would also be
very interesting to see how this would
play out with regards to long-form
discourse because we need to find
politicians you know one of the things
joe told me when i was talking to him
about joe rogan when i was talking to
him about his three-hour interviews i
said well does that ever not work out
for people and he says well yeah i've
had guests on who just run out of steam
at about 45 minutes
they don't have anything else to say and
we don't need politicians who run out of
steam at 45 minutes we need people who
can engage in intense discussion for
three hours without running out of
detail without running out of ideas
right a detailed grasp of the political
realm and we need to be able to see that
so we could move away from these like
six-minute cnn interviews and well yeah
it's moving away from the tweets and the
nonsense which to my mind is inherently
polarizing it's like look at what this
you know
hardcore lefty did on a college campus
or look at this most egregious example
of something that's over here and i'm
not saying those things aren't important
or that we don't have to pay attention
to them but the vast majority of people
in america right now
need real nuts and bolts solutions and
they're sick of corruption
maybe
maybe there's a technological rule here
so imagine that this is like we could
call this the peterson principle let's
say the narrower the bandwidth the more
likely polarized information will be
delivered over it
i think it's great but i think we should
call the hurwitz
principle you'll have to come up with a
more elegant formulation then but it
seems to me that that's highly probable
because if you have to compress complex
information into a very narrow channel
and and broadcast tv would would
certainly qualify and twitter of course
even worse is that you have to you have
to radically oversimplify it
right well and i'm always i'm always
torn between this because like i said
i've a lot of friends i mean across the
gamut of political orientations i read a
lot of news and follow a lot of people
across the political orientation like
all the way left to right not far right
or very far left but i'm talking about
within the reasonable
polls
and
it's it's just it's amazing to me how
skewed it is if you turn on msnbc and
then fox news we're in two different
worlds if you're the huffington post for
the drudge report and so it's very easy
to get like i think i have more of
awareness of what the
triggers are for conservatives and what
the triggers are for liberals but also
the fact that these triggers are getting
this outsized
air time constantly by this condensed
means of information and i think that's
where like the idw
like there's there's way more listeners
to you guys than makes any sense
like the fact that you had ten two and a
half hour lectures on the psychological
underpinnings of the bible and that more
than two people watch that makes no
sense and so there's a ton of people who
are really curious for more in-depth
analysis it's not being met elsewhere
and i think that's where the polls have
been missing i think that that's
proverbial proverbially the group of
people who are who are being missed and
who aren't being who aren't being
discounted yeah and
you know it's it's really important that
we have these this more in-depth
conversations about it
so that's our little conspiracy plan so
to speak then is
right right is to t to to inquire if the
people who've been loosely grouped
together
as the idw are willing to engage in
serious discourse with with to begin
with with centrist democrats doesn't
have to be limited to that but i think
that's a nice counter play too because
for me it can even be democrats who
aren't centrists who are tilting even
left of that
who are willing to engage in finding
reasonable discourse and might even have
like different districts and states have
different notions and it might really
make sense for
an aspect of the party that's further
left to test something in san francisco
or new york and see what new ideas come
out of it right it's just for me
it can't be with moral condescension and
it can't be a purity test you know you
and i talk so much about how the left
and the right get off track in different
ways yeah the right gets very fascistic
and you see them coming and it's it's
you know fascistic overlay we know what
that is historically it will go heavily
towards voter suppression there's a lot
of issues that are very highly
problematic on that side of the fence
and when they like it gets it gets uh
ethnocentric
in the superior sense right yeah yeah
and you know or or you know illegal or
hardcore power grabbing in a way that's
effective let's say
and with the left the left you know
cannibalizes and it's purity tests and
it goes kind of crazy that way i think
that we are seeing from the democrats
now an awareness that real solutions
need to be offered again anti-corruption
is a huge thing that i'm seeing
democrats start to tackle in a very
serious way healthcare jobs education
and it's really important that these
things get brought out and so for me
it's like we can test things that are
further that are further left and see if
workers don't work yeah
but we also need to do that from a
position that isn't morally
condescending in a position that's also
appreciative of different cultures in
different places around the country
what's going to work in up in new york
isn't going to work in alabama and
liberals are so good at i think in
understanding and appreciating other
cultures
you know like it's one of the things
that that is sort of a trademark but
it's interesting to me that that i think
we have fallen down on our understanding
of different cultures within the united
states
and so it's this very interesting divide
that like if it's foreign or perceived
as exotic it's all good but like we need
a better understanding of certain
cultures also um
you know like alabama and texas yeah
certainly is guilty of this too i mean
the right treats
chicago as if it's some like horrible
you know no man's land i'm not saying
this is a problem only of the left but
i'm saying we can really benefit with
conversations and i'm talking a lot of
candidates in oklahoma in orange county
in texas who have an understanding of
their constituents and what they want to
do is help them and to present a
reasonable alternative of real solutions
to them about real issues and not the
that everybody is engaging in
it's absolutely essential
and if we if we offer all that and lose
then tough luck we got to make a better
case we got to make a better argument
like we screwed up we got to try harder
yeah
by the way the other thing jordan that's
really heartening i'm seeing with a lot
of the actual candidates as opposed to
the noise
is more of an emphasis on personal
accountability you know it's it's about
helping people and creating new
opportunities for them economically but
in a way that empowers them with the
freedom to sort of make their life or
make their mark if that's a freedom that
they can seize it's about sort of trying
to level a baseline like we talked about
how healthcare can be super helpful for
business and for entrepreneurial
ventures
we talked about why it's essential for
the robustness of communities but it's
about setting the terms under which
people can be free to make choices and
to perform at a level that they want to
to build their whole future so it's not
that it's a shift from sort of us
running ahead and blocking for people
to us trying to lift the constraints so
that people can have better choices for
their for their families for their kids
in their education system for their own
work so that they can do better and make
their own mark
and because a lot of what we're standing
on a lot of the successes that we're
standing on as a country are on the
shoulders of working men and women
that's a lot of what's accounted for the
things that we've done well and in fact
a lot of the world frankly a lot of the
world has benefited enormously from the
working people of the united states yeah
you know in a way that i don't think
gets nearly enough recognition and so
yeah well i see the the accruing
financial success of the poor around the
world which is happening at a very rapid
rate
is in most part a consequence of
the
the sacrifices made either willingly or
unwillingly by the american working
class over the last 30 years absolutely
working class that's it
it's competition with the world has been
opened up at the level of the working
class first and that's been unbelievably
beneficial to the rest of the world and
probably a pretty good medium to
long-term strategy because well and the
american working class
it's like they have
they've built
affluence for people around the globe
like they're heroes there's no there's
no infantilizing of them
in a way that's derogatory and it's like
it's our job to make sure that they can
have choices for their future that they
that they are free to compete at least
with the same rules that everybody else
competes to differentiate themselves
because they've always kicked ass i mean
it's an amazing amazing workforce and
they've always done well
and it's like if people are complaining
about you know entitlements it's like we
can also look at corporate subsidies
it's like
it's not about one tilt or the other
it's about the same rules that people
need to differentiate themselves and
it's about creating more freedom for
them to reach their accomplishments well
it seems to me that the democrats would
have a lot more
success and and and
also be able to generate a counter
narrative to the radicals on the left if
they made the assumption that there's
all sorts of good things about free
market capitalism but crony capitalism
is not one of them yeah no and and
that's part of your emphasis on
let's call it uh uh um
regulation of corruption it's like the
free enterprise system works real well
except when it gets warped and twisted
and so we have to remove the warping and
twisting so that people do have the
opportunity to compete and to cooperate
as freely as possible and that's in
everyone's interests including
radical capitalists because to the
degree that the system is corrupt then
that reflects badly on the system and
produces a tremendous amount of
opposition towards it
absolutely
and you want to be it's like if you
can't win fairly what are you doing in
the game
like that's it it's to me it's a very
tough argument that's like
if you can't sign a pledge which which
has been put forth it's called the
disclose act there's a number of
variations of it that's no dark money
you know no for it's a strong stance
against interference by by
hostile actors it's no voter suppression
it's getting universal health care
universal um voter registration there's
a lot of stuff of like let's get
everybody out voting let's lift the
suppression and voter intimidation and
then win fair square and it's like for
me it's like i want the right to win
fairly and i want the right to lose
fairly if we make a better argument then
let's do it but you know it's also
anti-gerrymandering which is a really
big problem and there's a lot of people
who vow to not participate in
gerrymandering and to also have it be
either bipartisan committees or judges
who determine the boundaries yeah well
it's really it's really quite an outrage
that it's not bipartisan committees it's
ridiculous you know into a boxing ring
and telling someone that you're gonna
fight him but they can only step in
certain areas and you can go anywhere
and they can only hit you with a jab but
you get to use your full battery shots
it's like man up right step into the
arena if you think you can win and win
fair and square and there's a there's a
big emphasis i think that's not getting
enough press and democrats cleaning up
our side of the aisle in a way that is
accountable and that is is going to be
clear and this is
disagree with that i believe if you're
a heart you're a republican and you want
to win you should be aware that you can
win fairly and under the same rules and
that i mean we can all agree on that i
think yeah yeah well it would be nice if
the democrats too could help everyone
figuring out figure out what the
problems actually are because right now
mostly what we see in the media is a
discussion of pseudo problems
exactly and and so i'd like to see what
what are their what are the real um
challenges that confront us at the
moment and what are the proper solutions
to those challenges yeah it's so funny
because i feel like the the
racial discourse or discourse around
racism has gotten so loaded and so
complicated um since president trump is
his run or has taken office and it's i
feel like all sides of the issue are
like there's nowhere you can step
without being a landline and for me it's
really important to boil down to i went
with a program called the fi
that goes and um
runs an entrepreneurial program in the
prison system
and
it's absolutely unbelievable how
you know what i call the um the prison
industrial complex works the
privatization of prison and you can
sidestep all the arguments about who's
doing what and who's responsible
african americans
you know who are up for drug charges the
exact same drug charges as as whites
are 600 more likely to get put in prison
like that's a straight stat that's not
well they're doing more crime there's no
argument to be had about that
there are certain unbelievable biases of
how you know african americans and
people of color are put into a prison
system which profits from them and which
they're doing a lot of work and
basically you know no wages
it's very problematic anybody would
agree with that across the spectrum i
think if you look at those numbers and
it's patently unfair if there's one
thing we need to have a intelligent
discussion about drug policy that would
be a real start about the prison system
and who it stewed towards and the ways
in which it is unfairly implemented and
that's a no
major problem and
if you if you discuss the actual
hardcore facts
and if you can boil it down to those
things no one's going to disagree with
that so you know what you know what
bjorn lombard did this is really
interesting he's a he's a scandinavian
um
he used to be an environmentalist he
still is but he calls himself the
skeptical environmentalist now i really
like bjorn lomberg he wrote a great book
called how to spend 50 billion and then
a few laters years later 75 billion to
make the world a better place a book i
would highly recommend this is what he
did this is really nice procedural um
achievement
he looked at the un i hope i got this
story right it's a while since i since i
read it over the un puts out a lot of
development goals say like i think they
have 150 development goals something
like that and that's too many goals you
can't do 150 things and i worked on a un
committee for a while and we were trying
to prioritize the goals because you have
to prioritize things in order to
accomplish them and one of the things we
discovered was that you couldn't
prioritize the goals because every goal
had its constituents
and they were outraged if any other goal
was prioritized over theirs
and that was a terrible thing because
well that's like tragedy of the commons
because the goals couldn't be
prioritized and they couldn't be
then they couldn't be accomplished
essentially so lomberg figured out a way
around this so his idea was this okay so
there's a bunch of things that need to
be done because there's a bunch of
problems out there in the world and but
there's too many to simultaneously
address so we have to figure out where
we're going to start so what we're going
to do is a cost benefit analysis
so we're going to concentrate on doing
as much good for the least amount of
money as we can that's going to be our
initial um
strategy because why not right
um because money is a scarce resource
and it involves human labor and human
intelligence and all of that and so you
don't want to waste it
but he didn't believe that he would be
capable of doing the prioritization so
what he did was get 10 teams of
economists together some of which were
headed by world-class economists people
who won nobel prize and he had them
organized teams
and then he had them go through the
development goals and prioritize them
and make an economic case and so then
you had 10 separate cases i said here's
the rule you've got 50 billion dollars
you can spend it on whatever you want
but you have to justify it in terms of
cost benefit analysis and you have to
choose from this list
and so then he got each economist to
generate a list of their priorities then
he averaged across the lists and came up
with a final list of of both problems
which is a big deal right because the
first issue is what are the problems
that we need to solve like you know you
might think well what politicians should
be generating is answers it's like no no
that's not right if you're trying to
solve a complex problem a set of complex
problems the first thing you want to do
is formulate the problems properly and
then you work towards towards defining
what the solutions might be so be really
interesting to see if we could have an
intelligent political conversation that
would concentrate on on defining what
the actual problems are
and it's not capitalism versus socialism
right that's not a problem
what's fun is everyone gets to scream at
each other and then be superior and get
in zingers and get in retweets
without having to know anything about
anything right and there's no actual
motivation towards trying to come up
with solutions to the vast majority of
people who have who are dealing with
real problems and that's the part that
pisses me off is it's like it's this
masturbatory venture of discussing the
overall culture and you know if you turn
on the news it's these little sound
bites
of the most you know sort of tabloid
nature
of the furthest extremes versus nuts and
bolts discussions of what actually makes
sense okay so what we need to do
let's say generally speaking is we've
got to figure out what the problems are
like what what are the pro what are the
most serious problems that currently
confront us as a society that'd be a
nice start like what are the 15 most
most
uh crucial problems that confront us as
we move farther into the 21st century
that's a hard that's a hard question and
then
um
i think the first okay don't go ahead
well i mean the first thing for me
looking at the system is political
corruption and i'm not meaning that it
it either party i mean i have my
opinions about which party does that
more but neither one is perfect and the
average rating of congress right now is
i'm sorry it's 18 percent is the
approval rating of congress which is
better or worse says is slightly above
syphilis um it ain't good and if you
don't believe that the people in
government are serving your needs and
are instead
you know more interested in furthering
the big money donors over the interests
of people which is proven out time and
time again
that's a huge problem when trust is
eroded that the people representing you
are representing rich donors rather than
average americans than seem to your
needs you can't get anywhere and i think
that's part of what's so important about
this pledge that a lot of democrats are
working on it's not it's a pledge to say
here's what we here's what we will
disclose and here's ways that we will
clean up our side of the aisle and i
think if it's it's essential it's
essential that you start with your own
reflection of fixing the things that you
need to fix in order to make a better
argument for me corruption and
government's the top of the list here
but go ahead well
i was thinking more of it procedurally
not not so much in terms of what the
problems might be i mean one of the
problems i see emerging well
one of them would be this increase in
political polarization which i think is
very very dangerous
i think another potential problem on the
horizon is something like
as our society becomes more cognitively
complex which is happening very very
rapidly the number of people the
proportion of people who are likely to
be dispossessed as a consequence of
of of
of
of lesser ability to deal with that kind
of complexity that problem is going to
increase and that's across the board and
it isn't obvious
what to do about that i don't really buy
guaranteed basic income solutions in
part because i don't think that money is
actually the solution to the problem of
what to do in life like money can stave
off well almost in some ways it's the
office if you lose a goal that you're
striving for that makes life tough and
this is an example of a conversation
that i think should be a round table
with democrats and conservatives and
republicans to say
what's a pro-capitalist argument for how
we're going to train people and bring
them along right
what's what's it what's a you know a
liberal argument for having concern for
people who don't have the same
advantages from the same background yeah
well you know the silicon valley types
they tend to skew pretty heavily liberal
and that's because they're generally
creative and entrepreneurial but they're
very rapidly building a world in which
people who are at the lower end of the
cognitive distribution are going to be
adrift
right and we need to fix that from both
sides so rather than saying
all or nothing right like tough luck
capitalism free market forget it or
you know we need to support every single
person in every single way
that has to be the subject of
complicated in-depth conversations with
people weighing in from a variety of
different political views it just has to
be
in order it's so complicated um
it's so complicated that we need we need
opinions and brains from all side of the
issues that's for sure we definitely
might also need different test cases
well you can also think about that
those tough conversations you know like
between someone who leans very liberal
and someone like ben shapiro you can
think about those as stress tests
you know damn stupid solution which
you've put a lot of effort into
elaborating let's say can't withstand
the stress of a single argument with
someone who disagrees with you what the
hell do you what makes you think that's
going to work when you implement it in
the real world
obviously it's going to fail merely
because those people are going to object
to it
independent of its objective merits
and so if if it can't fly with your
opponents i mean i'm not talking about
the fringe opponents because nothing
flies with the fringe except what the
fringe believes but
i also think that the fringe is overly
represented and that's what's so hard
like
like when mark duplass apologized for
saying people should follow ben shapiro
right there was an apology he put forth
it was i haven't worked with with with
duploss i mean i've heard he's a
terrific guy and i think that his aim
was sort of a furtherance of of
an ending of polarization and discourse
i don't know who
who are all those people who are
personally deeply wounded by him saying
that you should just follow somebody
whether you agree with him or not and i
also don't know who the apology is
geared towards like who is he
apologizing to and if we have sort of a
mob dictate i mean the one thing i say a
lot and this is especially true in
hollywood is there's a huge and widening
gap between conversations that people
are having in public and what they
really believe in private yeah that's
the sign of a creeping totalitarianism
that's really really dangerous yeah
and it's also from both sides i'm not
just saying that this is this is a
liberal value i think there's a lot more
people who have more complicated views
that they don't feel safe to articulate
because fear of complete reputation
slandering right they'll be out of work
it'll be everything else and so i don't
it's a very interesting thing
i have a lot of
sympathy for people who step out and say
something and then sort of retreat and
apologize because i feel like the force
of a mob response from the fringe even
if it's sort of pluralistic about
ignorance right i mean 90 of people
might agree with you but if the ten are
allowed and it's all that you're seeing
everywhere
it has the power to warp reality yeah
that's how mind control cults function
you know mind control calls one of the
first things they do if they can get you
off your complex is privacy deprivation
and everywhere that you look
if there's two versions they try and
split me i went undercover to mind
control cults to research one of my
novels and when you're there everything
that i say that is
colt's greg they're splitting colt greg
from greg greg
and everything that i say is like wow
this is fun it's sort of love bombing
everyone leans in it's direct eye
contact it's sort of like non-sexual
touching everyone's engaged but if i say
you know this is weird i kind of you
know miss being in contact with someone
other friends it's the sort of
windshield that everyone's back
and
it's what i think is happening but from
a smaller percentage of people
that but they're really really loud
and if you see it all of a sudden it
seems to be the reality when you're
getting yeah yeah
there's this sort of apologies that i
don't believe when a lot of people make
the apologies they read flat to me it
doesn't feel heartfelt and also like
let's say you really did screw up like
part of what we need to do is screw up
part of what we need to do is think
about things and say things and overstep
and go wow that was kind of a screw-up
yeah
apology to society versus individual
stuff to say hey i've afforded this
position
i wish i'd articulated it better i don't
always explain myself perfectly yeah you
probably what i should have said rather
than i'm so sorry to have had a thought
that is it isn't appropriate and we're
seeing this across the boards and i
think it's really well part of what
needs to be done and this is something
we already talked about is to
is to generate better dialogue yeah that
isn't like that and hope that the mere
fact that it's of much higher quality is
sufficient to attract people to it and
away from this other nonsense
yes it's hard because as you said the
shorter the span like i have people
who who know that we're good friends you
know our work is kind of tangled up we
mentioned each other in our books we've
known each other since i was in you
know 20 years old
and people will say well he believes in
course monogamy like dismissed it'll be
one thing and it's like it's an
anthropological term or sociological
term with specific meaning that takes
one google search to sort of prove that
it's not that jordan peterson is running
around like in a world war ii propaganda
poster like dragging women off into the
caves and giving them giving them to
useless men right i mean but it's so
disprovable but it's also so damning on
a format like twitter where you have you
know 280 characters yeah and so it's
that it's that reputation thing where
like if you associate with you you
should never be discussed again if you
you should follow ben shapiro whether
you agree with him or not
you have to be bombarded and shamed
until you apologize for even saying that
you'll do that and it's like look i've
learned the most from my friends who
disagree with me the most
i have a wide range of friends it's so
funny that one of the stories that i
tell
after president trump was elected i was
in vegas on a book tour and one of my
friends was a crusty old armor and
sniper from the spec ops community he
passed away recently but he was just a
great friend and a great guy
and i did a lot of shooting with him for
the books i did a lot of research and he
wanted me to see his ranch and we pull
up to his ranch and he has a tank parked
in his front yard and sticking out of
the out of the end of it is a trump pen
sign so at that exact moment
my wife
sends me a text and it's her and my
daughter at like one of the you know
thousand women marches and they just
come up on miley cyrus so they're like
my daughter's posing with miley cyrus
and the text sort of comes in my buddy
looks at me he goes what's that and i
looked up at him i said nothing
but then i showed him and we had a good
laugh about it in sort of this way
that that it's like you need people
around you have a whole variety of
things and one thing that was
interesting with him was around the time
of the muslim ban i was talking to him a
lot about that and i i'm personally very
post-muslim band for instance but
there's there's a lot of reasons if you
talk to people
in the military there's a lot of
problems recruiting translators now like
that has a negative effect that rippled
through the intelligence community it's
not good
and you know and whether i have friends
who are vehement advocates of this but
i'm arguing with them saying what is the
actual ground truth of how that is
affecting things and then there's other
people in the military who are like this
has been a total show it's really
hurting our intelligence efforts and our
allies
i feel like that's the level of the
discussion or one of the other things
for me that's very relevant is you know
i don't know if you if you know this but
there's 15 000 muslim physicians from
the seven band muslim countries in
america and they predominantly work in
in rural red state districts they're
providing the majority of not the
majority they're providing a ton of
medical care
to a lot of people in red states and by
the way those are the people if they
fled aleppo they hate bashir al-assad
and extremism like this is this is this
is exactly the sorts of people who you
want to have in these areas and if
they're pulled out we're going to have a
lot of rural areas that more affluent
physicians
are not going to have access to medical
care um because more affluent physicians
or people from america don't always want
to go to
these regions there's a lot of like
bigger recruiting of physicians so you
have these people who are who are great
sort of citizens and representatives who
hate extremism who are treating people
in deep red states and it's like that's
really important and you pair that with
the intel picture that i think is deeply
problematic
and you have a sort of argument that
isn't just you should have more empathy
for muslims which then just deteriorates
into well they're terrorists and it like
it just devolves rather looking at sort
of the temperament of the people who are
here and you have to have conversations
with people from all sides of the uh
like i had a lot of conversations with
people in the military who support it
are against it to kind of start to zero
in on what where my position is
okay so the plan is something like this
so
we'll we've recorded this video i'm
going to post it as in public invitation
to the intellectual dark web i think
that's what i'll title it or subtitle it
the idea would be to
bring on people democrats at least to
begin with because that would sort of
run counter to the idw reputation let's
say
democrats who are capable and will
capable of and willing to engage in
long-form discussions about complex
high-resolution issues and to provide a
more at least in part a more centrist
alternative to the radical leftists but
also to bring on people with more
left-leaning views to have them
uh
try their
arguments out in a more um
in a more fully-fledged manner something
like that yeah i mean i think how does
anyone lose like if someone's
conservative and not moving they should
know what the reasonable version is of
the argument they're rejecting like good
for you then you know yeah all that
they're seeing is reports of like
students gone wild on college campuses
and the craziness that i believe i
believe is a problem i mean you've
certainly you've dealt with protests and
you've dealt with that sort of
like brutal um
group think and anti uh first amendment
you know like sort of shutting down
speech it's always tricky to talk about
freedom of speech and first amendment
because it's unclear always where that
lapses into being legal or
constitutional versus just people
articulating things loudly but i have no
question that that's a problem but i
think that there's i think that it is
over represented and amplified by the
media and by both sides of the media
yeah i think so too sexier topic and i
think we should get people in who are
willing to have conversations that are
solution geared so that if people
realize that
see for me part of what my interest is
is in sort of trying to transcend
politics and getting a place where like
i don't care if you're a republican or
democrat as much as i care if you're
offering real solutions yes right
exactly so then the other element of
this would be to figure out what the
problems are to see if we can come to
some sort of consensus about
where the challenges that confront us
really lie
right and if there's a democrat running
for office who is very dark money
embedded and beholden to donors and
there's somebody who's a a cleaner uh
choice who's running who's a republican
it's like let's have that out you know
it's not this is this is about actually
starting to figure out solutions for for
for people in terms of the level of
discourse that we can have and the
solutions that need to be offered
because while we're here talking about
all this stuff there's a lot of people
dealing with a lot of real life problems
okay okay so all i've started to
introduce you to a number of people
you've met sam and you met dave rubin um
you met douglas murray briefly who else
who else have i introduced you to
um
a number of other peripheral people or
or other crews but i think you know i i
there's a number of people i'd like to
talk to to start at this viewpoint
um and the viewpoint that's more aligned
with my politics represented um
so you know we'll keep we should we
should keep at it and we i think that
the aim for me there's a couple aims i
mean the aim is to sort of end
polarizing discourse raise the level of
conversation that can be had for actual
solutions that we need for actual people
and the sort of long-term aim for me
is just to to to eliminate the levels of
corruption in the government and that's
across the boards either side that's a
long-term aim for me is like who's
willing to sign on to a disclose act
who's willing to say that they're gonna
disclose all their donors everyone who
paid for an ad
who's willing to not take pac money as
individual candidates um you know who's
willing to stand up against
gerrymandering and that to me is party
agnostic that's who's willing on that
yep
okay
well
sounds like a plan all right
all right i'll start i'll start the ball
rolling on my end i've got some people
that i want you to meet on the
republican end of the distribution as
well great i'm happy to meet with anyone
who is you know reasonable and willing
to have discourse instead of chess beat
yep okay good good talking to you greg
bye